so good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
we'd like to begin welcome to the second
day of our conference on polish
ukrainian relations past present and
future yesterday's session was more
devoted to the past two historical
issues to controversies that people
discussed both during and after the
conference and will probably be talking
about today and for some time this
afternoon we're happy to present
contemporary issues and our first panel
this afternoon is moderated by Vanessa
Brown from Freedom House she will
introduce the speakers for you and make
sure that there is some border in our
meeting this afternoon and we'd like to
let you know that when this meeting is
over that there is a reception down at
the ukrainian institute at seventy-ninth
Street and fifth avenue and i believe
the reception starts at six o'clock
you're welcome to come thank you today
speakers are she stopped sympathy and
both yet mr. soon as he's done
democracy Foundation which is a private
non governmental nonprofit organization
of establishing the 1980s republic
corporation of Polish American educators
and foundations goal is for the wohlers
about democracy at a free market economy
and provide for civic activity and
democratic state the Foundation's
initial task is great assistance in this
field to educators and after the tsunami
Verma told Tribune we've and local
government organizations in forwarding
other countries of Central and Eastern
Europe mr. boss man has a chairman of
the e-magazine organization and that
energy of the journal of the same name
is also the new culture local scientists
as a public organization media magazine
establishes the fundamentals of civic
society Ukrainian through its clearly
defined position of the support of the
shooter societal and political
country will have a super-secret awesome
in minutes today and the TT followed by
the question
permit of nov son of the pine straw
ladies and gentlemen the year of poland
in ukraine became almost invisible as
and republishing wrote in visca gazeta
it began without fanfare without
presidential head shaking and without
visible media coverage that this means
that this year isn't important does it
means that it's unnecessary during these
20 minutes I would like to share with
you the experience of experiences of
land last 10-15 years experiences of
cooperation between non-governmental
organizations from Poland and from you
kind usually the international relations
are traditionally linked with the
government's with the states in the case
of the Poland and Ukraine usually they
are also operated by the historians
today's story is the story about this
groups in the civil society in Poland
and in Ukraine which are the most active
which really believes that we can make a
change which really believes that we can
influence the history if you are
thinking about distillations we have to
remember the last 15 years what happened
what important changes happened in this
at this time we have to remember about
the establishment of independent
ukrainian state we have to remember that
after many many years the border became
open but also we have to remember that
the equation of
important censorship are allowed to open
all the discussions or the walls or the
conflicts from the past this situation
could easy bring to the conflict to the
going back to the past to the quarrels
and what we see today in Poland and in
Ukraine is that in spite of this purse
in spite of the history and in spite
Poland general trend of political
economic engagement with the West we can
see substantial increase of the interest
of poor in Ukraine and Ukrainians in
last 10 years we are really surprised to
see that this interests are not first of
all